[Music]
how long have you been writing about us
he lived his life for himself
and then it shifted
[Music]
say
hardin has so many demons i was young in
love and i was terrified
but he's trying to be better for me
i'll just keep dragging you into my [ __ ]
tess and his mom
[Music]
i don't know if i can keep fighting to
save him rather than myself
we need time apart
you can't just escape yourself by moving
from one place to another
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a bidding war
for my book
i don't want people reading about my
life this is our lives what is the point
in everything we've been through if we
can't channel that into something that
helps people it's about forgiveness and
unconditional love
that is the kind of story after us
after
it's my journey after i met you
[Music]
you're gonna get arrested you know that
which is why you should leave
you weren't here when she needed you now
you're making it worse
[Music]
you are pushing every ounce of my
self-control you have no idea
[Music]
you